what are three key points every
filmmaker should know about getting a
movie made
i would say point number one and this is
remember i'm talking about a filmmaker
who has the intention to make money
okay to sell their film because if their
intention is just to create
a movie that is artistic that they want
to finish and put on their shelf and
enjoy
that's not what i'm talking about so if
we're talking about somebody who has
makes a movie the intention of making a
profit on it selling it and hopefully
making a profit
the first thing they should do they have
to
they have to think about who they're
going to sell it to who the audience is
who they're making the movie for
that's number one number two is
so number one is identifying the
audience number two is
how they gonna market to that audience
so now they know what audience they
wanna get to
but how they gonna get there how are
they going to
what publicity campaign what social
media campaign whatever
are they going to use to get to that
audience
now you might be thinking yourself you
asked me about
you know about making a movie and i'm
talking about selling a movie
i honestly believe that if you want to
make money with your movie
as i would say for any business or any
product not just a movie
you got to be thinking about your
audience and how to market them
before you even make your movie and then
number three would be how to deploy your
funds
as effectively as possible so that
you're getting as we talked about before
the most
of your money on screen so you're making
the best product possible
don't waste your time and make a crappy
product you'll regret it
and it won't sell so make what you make
something that you're going to be proud
of that you feel like you're going to
you know have a shot to sell
but before you do that make sure you
know who you're making it for and that
you have it
and you have an avenue to get to them
whether it be through a distributor or
through your own means or through your
own you know friends or whatever
marketing you're gonna do
now i tell people this this is this is
where
indie filmmakers really really struggle
with what i'm about to say and this is
what i say to them
i say when you're budgeting for a movie
make sure that if you want to be
successful
if your movie is going to spend if
you're going to spend 500 000
on making your movie spend at least at
least
300 000 on marketing it like
you have to have like 60
somewhere between 60 and 100 of your
production budget you also have to have
for a marketing budget
and they say that's crazy how are we
going to do that we can hardly
raise enough money to make the movie how
are we going to raise money to market
the movie
and i say if you want to have a shot
like if you want to compare yourself to
hollywood movies and studio movies look
at what they do
i mean everything every single movie
they put out has a gigantic marketing
budget
in some cases it's you know the
production budget and the marketing
budget are the same
even on a 50 million dollar movie
marketing budget might be more actually
i mean that's what makes it successful
because hollywood movies
understand i mean studios understand
that it's one thing to make a great
movie but it's
it's nothing unless you can get it in
front of an audience and you have to
advertise it to them
indie filmmakers don't necessarily do
that so remember the two
things that i led with were know where
your audience is and and make sure you
have you know
the wherewithal to get to them which is
usually involves resources
so make sure that when you're budgeting
you
tuck a big chunk of money aside for
marketing
that's funny i've listened to a lot of
your webcasts here a lot of filmmakers
talk about it and they talk
about make sure you have enough money i
mean it's most people
say make sure you have enough money for
post-production when i listen to those
and i say are you kidding me like
post-production is part of making the
movie
like you actually went and shot a film
and didn't think about post production
like that's
crazy then then to me it's crazy like i
would never do that i would never go
into production
without having enough money to finish
the movie because what's the point of
that
secondly some people who are you know a
little further along
say make sure you have enough for
delivery because it's expensive to
deliver you have to
you know there's elements you have to do
to deliver i also say
of course you have to deliver i mean
that's all part of like that's part of
the production
budget but how many indie filmmakers
ever say make sure you have enough to
market
and it's painful to say that it's
actually painful because
if you have an extra quarter of a
million dollars and you're sitting
and you know it's tucked away there for
marketing you're inclined to spend it on
the movie
i'll make a way better movie i'll say
five quarter million dollars more
think of how i could spend it think of
how good the movie could be but then you
got nothing left to market it with
so no matter how good a movie you made
you yeah you can't market it
now here's what you'll ask me and here's
what everybody says but that's the
distributor's job to market it it's not
my job to market it it's the distributor
so i'm going to get a distributor
and they're going to spend the quarter
of a million dollars to market it that's
what they do
and i say maybe that means
first of all you got to get lucky and
get a distributor secondly
there aren't too many distributors these
days who are going to spend a quarter
million dollars marketing an indie movie
so you better like if you really really
want to get behind your movie and and
you really believe in it and you want to
have a shot at getting it successful
tuck that money aside raise extra money
put it in
and tell your investors they'll actually
respect that they will respect the fact
that you're actually thinking about
marketing
as much as you're thinking about
production tuck it aside
and if you do get a distributor if you
do get lucky and get a good distributor
have them deploy those resources on your
behalf
so that they have you know a war chest
to help get the movie out it's only
going to be to your benefit
i mean there are some tricks on how to
make that happen so they don't
beat you and take fees on your own money
and take costs and all that kind of
stuff we'll have to talk about that at
some point
um so like don't just throw it in their
laps because they'll spend it and you
won't get any return on it
but if and and the other thing is if you
don't get a distributor
you may have to self-distribute and if
you're going to self-distribute you need
to
have some resources to do that with it
it's not good enough to throw out you
know just a crappy
social media campaign these days it's
too crowded out there nobody's going to
see it
you have to spend some money well what
about cream rises to the top
so if i get it on one of these streaming
services it's
it i don't need to it's gonna it's gonna
don't worry it'll be suggested yeah
that's the typical thing
if if i get it on a streaming service do
you know what the odds of getting an
australian service
are that would be like if i or people
say if i get it into sundance
then you know you know a big company
will see it and i will let's talk about
sundance that's okay that's like the
streaming company all right
it's the same type of deal right getting
a movie into an indie movie into
sundance now is almost impossible
i mean it the acceptance rate is so low
it's like getting accepted to ucla for
college students like 114
000 applications and 3 000 spots it's
extremely extremely low all right so the
chances of you getting accepted
into sundance with your indie film are
very very low but let's say you're one
of the lucky ones
and you actually do get it in all right
that's not enough
because the next thing you have to do is
you have to get a screening time
that like it's about getting the
screening where
buyers will actually come so i'm using
sundance because it's one of the major
festivals and we know that there are
lots of
acquisition executives and you know and
movie buyers who could make a difference
who could make your movie
but it has to be seen you have to spend
a
fortune you have to hire a publicist
first of all you have to
hopefully get a good screening time if
it's nine in the morning and there's
parties the night before nobody's coming
to your screening
you have to get an afternoon or i mean
that's hard to do right you got to get
lucky with that
now you get that so now you've gotten
lucky twice you have to hire
a publicity team and a you know a
promotion team
you can't just assume people are going
to come somebody's got to be talking it
up that costs a lot of money to hire
those people
especially at sundance where it's super
competitive and where it's hard to get
the attention of the buyers because they
only want to see the big movies
so that's when i said a lot of money
that could be anywhere from five to ten
thousand dollars
minimum minimum all right not to mention
you have to be at sundance and spend
your money to be there and all that kind
of stuff
so now you get the buyers there likely
your publicity person will say you have
to have a party because afterwards you
have to entertain them and they
have to schmooze with you and blah blah
blah blah blah there's another 10 to 20
grand maybe down the toilet
but this is what you're competing with
this is what studios do so it's not like
oh everybody says
i'll get into sundance and i'll be
setting you know and then you got to
hope that somebody's in a good mood and
that they liked your champagne
and it was expensive enough that they
want to make you an offer
so there's a lot that goes into it same
with the streaming service what
you think you pick up the phone and call
netflix and say oh i just made a great
film oh that's great send it over you
know
it doesn't work that way you could wait
years and years and years before
anybody even sees it so or you can get
lucky
but you can't i don't depend on luck
you